Thank you for all you do. What are your thoughts and experience with bladder cancer?
Well, just like bladder cancer, just like any other cancer to me every cancer is different even if you know
two brothers come in with bladder cancer. Okay, we still treat them
very differently. So we do with cheek swab, we test for what they need and they could come up with a completely different protocol.
So everybody's unique in our book. So I don't like here's the protocol for bladder cancer.
It my book that doesn't really exist. So we want to be as specific as possible and test them to see what they would need.
You know, it could be totally different protocol for those two brothers.
As far as the right frequencies go, the right frequencies would be similar if not this exact same frequencies for bladder cancer.
So with any cancer, I just think, you know, obviously if you look at our website, go to cuttersclinic.com you'll see
why we like the right. I mean, the right is what got me into helping people with cancer way back to the late 90s.
And I just think you're just foolish not using the right machine while you're doing an oxidative stress, you know,
protocol or while you're doing chemo therapy while you're doing whatever you're doing.
I think the right is a great compliment to help whatever you're doing work better.
So contact us through that clinic. You can see that in that clinic website if you want.